hey samuel how are you hi morgan how are
you
i'm great you are just one of those
actors that i will watch you in anything
you're my favorite actor and you are
exceptional in this series what was this
whole experience like for you and and
what the feeling what was the feeling
that you got when you actually watched
the series back
um wow i
watched it recently it's been a while
since i watched it um but
it's a
it's a it's a great sense of fulfillment
i've been trying to get this done for
you know a good
i don't know 10 12 years now so it's
kind of uh great to finally see it all
come to
come to fruition and to see all the
different characters uh on screen the
ensemble that we pulled together to meet
all the different people in it were
perfect
it's it's hard to imagine
even though in my head i always say that
i see things before they happen
when i saw this i saw it as being this
wonderful but all these people brought
you know things and energy that are very
different than what i have kind of
imagined yeah no every character is so
memorable i know you were a fan of the
novel that you actually reached out to
the author in terms of wanting to adapt
this for the screen what was it about
this story that spoke to you personally
um well i've been surrounded by dementia
and alzheimer's for a pretty good while
between you know my grandfather my mom
her brother her sister uh people on my
father's side uh so i've seen it a lot
and i've watched the light guard in a
lot of people's eyes and it was um
kind of moving
to read this novel and to have a
question put
if you could
be cured for
a specific amount of time would you do
it so you could go back and fix all the
things you know that you did wrong in
your life uh and it's a great question
uh and it's an interesting drama to
pursue
with um a lot of other people around uh
to tell parts of the story the family
drama the love life that you know he had
and lost
the
young girl that comes into his life and
reclaims him from life's kind of sort of
junkie because his family's kind of
discarded him uh and he's isolated she
comes in and you know gives him a worth
and becomes uh a better person herself
because of it
yeah absolutely um you know it was
really fascinating watching the the
different
times in tommy gray's life and i know
that you spent a lot of time in the
makeup chair every day about 90 minutes
getting into you know the physical
aspect of this character
what did you do to pass that time
um
well
uh my makeup artist jake garber and i've
been together for a while he's he's he's
been with me through
three four or five movies and camille's
come with me since she came into the
business and was apprenticing under my
first hairdresser robert so we have lots
to talk about lots to laugh about and we
talk about projects people things places
times and we listen to good music
and sing yeah i like that i want to see
the behind the scenes videos of this now
i think there is one
i'm gonna go find it um and you know
before i get the wrap uh you know
dominique is so fantastic in this series
and your scenes are so good what do you
think we can learn from the relationship
between mr green robin um
that there is a connection that
if young people open their hearts and
their minds to talk to older people
they'll you know learn a lot
and old people tend to listen to young
people and they learn too
because they want to feel young and be
young and understand what it means to be
young
in their time and it's a very symbiotic
relationship that could you know work
out and probably solve a lot more
problems than uh people are allowing to
happen
yeah no i completely agree listen you
were so good in this it's so nice
getting to talk to you congratulations
thank you we're in canada i'm toronto oh
p.o
[Music]